hey guys what's up
we just finished one monster verse
comparison video and now we are back
with another and this one will be all
about the comparison between Toho's
1990s Mothra leo and wants to verse 2019
Titanus missourah we will include stats
like size powers speed agility other
abilities and even evolution these two
versions of Mothra are very similar to
each other but also at the same time
they spot various differences that split
them apart and make them distinct so
before you continue on with this video
be sure to LIKE share and subscribe for
more related content and also check out
our channel as we have more than 80
videos and oh yeah do smash a
notification bell for regular updates
our new and upcoming videos so let us
get on with this video showcase into you
the comparison of the 1990s Mothra Leo
vs monster verse 2019 Titanes mizura
origins in the rebirth of moral universe
Leo and Mothra
were the last remaining members of a
highly advanced species of giant moths
created as gardens to the Elias an
ancient civilization of small yet
powerful humanoids far older than
humanity Leo first appeared as an egg
laid by an agent and wicked Mothra in
1996 he then hatched prematurely during
a battle between his mother and a
monster [ __ ]
desgidora and despite being hopelessly
outmatched in his lava form he attacked
his mother's aggressor while for most of
us missourah it is said that from erased
Nazca lines to the Hidden Temple of the
moth the name Mothra is woven throughout
the most secret mythologies of the
planet the folklore and fairy tales tell
of a winged creature of blinding light
an angel of the clouds whose godlike
luminescence has the power to share of
the sky the most reverse of Matra
deviates from that of the original
Touhou incarnation is that she is not a
mystical divine being but rather a
member of titans momo sura
a prehistoric insect like super species
that originated from the same era as
Godzilla and the other tyrants
Godzilla species in particular had a
warm symbiotic relationship with
Mothra's
design the larval stage the lava is
distinct for the Leo Mothra in that its
body is a very light shade of brown with
very pronounced dark spots all over its
body the body is also very elongated and
slender the head is much more rounded
than later designs and features a tall
forehead the Leo lavas eyes are a light
blue color and are very small and
surrounded by large rounded sockets the
Leo lavas mandibles are relatively small
and the feelers flanking them are thin
and located near the bottom of the head
the most of us Motors design is very
different from past incarnations of the
character her larval stage Minty's
appearance of a giant segmented
caterpillar the segments of her body are
rounded and her head is very small
compared to the rest of her body the
legs of the larval form are larger and
more visible in that they have been in
past designs instead of the large
oval-shaped eyes of the imago stage
motors larval stage has small blue eyes
Motors larval stage possesses several
bioluminescent patches which emit the
soft blue light when she is calm but
change to a red color when she feels
Tretton and is poised to attack design
the adult stage Mothra leo takes on many
different forms and appearances his
wings are somewhat more triangular and
have different designs and color schemes
his abdomen is more rounded and less
defined than Mothra's leo also has green
eyes tree beats on his forehead and
feather like antennae resembling those
of a male moth as aqua Mothra
Leo's appearance is more streamlined and
he lacks fur Leo's wings are replaced
with four fins and he also gains fins on
his tail rainbow moivre's designs
however changes with a less bulky body
thinner legs and backward-facing
antennae his form in light speed Mothra
looks almost identical to Aqua Mothra
but it's blurry due to the quick
movement as our montmatre
leo possesses a silvery armored shell
around his body with sharp jagged wings
with different patterns and in his final
form eternal mantra he looks very
similar to our mammarra only without the
shell and wood white fur all over its
body most of us Mothra's imago state has
a segmented insect-like body with six
legs and two wings her legs are
considerably different from those of
past mothers designs the most of us
mother has two long hind legs with two
joints and two claw toes she has four
volumes two on each side of her body
with one large pair and one smaller pair
her forums are longer and more muscular
than those of past designs and N in
latch hook claws matras head is
comparatively smaller than it usually is
Matra has two gigantic compound wings
each composed of two segments a larger
segment near the front of her body and a
smaller segment towards the rear the
wings possess intricate patterns with
the character's traditional orange
yellow and black coloration which can
emit by luminescent glows that shift in
color now we come to size since Mothra
leo has seven different forms in his
larval form he is 25 meters long and
weighs 3000 tonnes in his imago and
rainbow form he is 24 metres long 5900
tonnes in weight and has a wingspan of
53 metres from tip to tip his aqua form
weighs 3,500 tons and has a wingspan of
30 meters which is the same as light
speed formed by the ladder weighs five
thousand nine tons
the only difference is from armored and
eternal Mothra is that they have wing
spans of 50 metres and they weigh 5000
magnet tons each in most of us Godzilla
king of the monsters Mothra was first
seen as a very big larvae that hatch
inside an old temple although the
estimates for the size of the larvae
wasn't given it could be said that this
incarnation was around 20 to 25 metres
long but we cannot say anything about
the weight and even for the adult the
only specifications given was that she
was 52 feet tall or 16 meters in height
and has a massive wingspan that Dwarfs
any other Mothra version at 803 feet or
to her 44 meters wide
physical abilities the lava for Mothra
Leo can move at 40 km/h while Mothra Leo
flies at speeds of up to Mach 15 point 5
when further evolves as acqua Mothra he
swims up to 200 knots the Lightspeed
Mothra can fly at speeds of over a
hundred and eighty six thousand miles
per second which is a speed of light are
memorialized at speeds of up to Mach 15
and this form uses razor-sharp wings and
also has an armored wing cutter the only
form of Mothra leo with physical traits
that can stand up against other
opponents in a melee barrel is armored
Mothra not only that but he also lifted
de guerra and King Ghidorah
who weighed seventeen thousand and
twenty thousand tons respectively the
most of us Mothra however can swiftly
blindside Ghidorah by gluing him to the
side of a building with a silk hat
gigantic wings allowed to fly across the
sky at great speeds furthermore she also
has two long hind legs with two joints
and two claw toes this version of Mothra
was able to fight an airborne melee
battle against Rodin and hold her own
against the fire demon she was seen
using her claws to a great extent in
both offensive and defensive moves
Matra also possesses a wasp like stinger
at the end of the her abdomen that is
powerful enough to punch a hole to
rodents Jess intelligence Mothra leo is
a steadfast guardian of the earth
charging into action whenever the Elias
call upon him and fighting until his
strength is spent even against vastly
more powerful foes even though he can
react and even sympathise with other
humans and his species
Matra leo is only intelligent to an
extent and he relies a lot on guidance
from his twin fairies
most of us Mothra however is a very
intelligent albeit not a divine being at
first Matra showed signs of curiosity
and inquisitiveness at a monarch
personal surrounding her however she
becomes aggressive when they try to
container and webs up some of them with
herself attacks when Emma
amidst the alpha frequency from the Orca
mantra immediately calms down later in
the show she was seen to react with
Godzilla's low energy and help the
humans locate him
she shares a symbiotic relationship and
even sacrifices herself for the g-man
durability mantra Leo's formed like
rainbow the imago and eternal form have
relatively lesser durable exoskeletons
an aqua mantra which is adapted for high
pressures underwater and they are also
lesser than Lightspeed mantra which by
the definition of his name he flies at
an unfathomable speed and therefore has
an extra powerful exoskeleton and last
the armored Mothra was able to defeat
Ghidorah and not take a scratch from the
space dragon
most of us motorists bodily tissue is
substantially harder than it seemed even
after sustaining burns and injuries from
rodents assaults she can fight at near
full strength and even temporarily take
on the full force of Ghidorah gravity
beams although she did die at en but as
she did not have divine powers like neo
her normal Titan body was surprisingly
tough enough to challenge the false King
and now we come to powers Mothra leo is
truly an offensive power house with many
abilities including the triple rainbow
cross heat laser beams from the forehead
Jade bolts from the wings a mega brass
cannon from thorax reflective green
powder from the wings that weaken and
cause pain to other monsters in an excel
pile load which is flying straight up
and emitting Jade rings he can also
perform a sparkling pile road maneuver
which our blue energy columns that can
split the earth another power is the Sun
strike Buster which is the releasing
whirpool of power culminating in an
emerald energy blast from the center and
also he possesses the ability to split
into thousands of footlong Mothra Leo's
armored Mothra is covered in armor with
razor-sharp wings our mother can fire an
armored heat laser from the forehead and
after building up enough energy he can
perform the unstoppable transcending
fate maneuver
most of us Mothra possesses a stinger in
her abdomen unlike the former who
stinger can fire armor-piercing darts
Massa vs. motor stinger acts as a last
resort weapon to incapacitate a target
motorist or axe is capable of emitting
better wave bioluminescent waves that
can be projected through parents of her
wings and weaponized as a blinding god
ray that are able to disperse clouds
Matra can form symbiotic relationships
with other kaiju such as Godzilla and
this motor can launch incredibly strong
so from the glands inside her mouth so
anyway this brings us to the end of the
video and we all can see from this
comparison is that most of us Mothra
only leads in one category and that is
size compared to more thoroughly oh she
does not even come close to matching the
power and durability of this divine moth
but this is up to debate and that is up
to you guys and girls to take it out in
the comment section so do like share and
subscribe for more related content on
this channel and do you hit that
notification bell